[Music]
in winnie be accused news
we need like ISM winnie-the-pooh yeah
okay oh I heard about this submitted by
sorry David you know the Winnie the Pooh
voice is being accused of rape and
animal abuse Oh what the doggie
maybe it's separate thing Paul maybe
though maybe [ __ ] you're I didn't notice
a comma in there dear he could be right
so what Winnie the Pooh era though he
[ __ ] oh he's the one that's been the
voice of Winnie the Pooh he [ __ ] the
bear he did the voice though it doesn't
count
no it's not he's a huge rapist in the
jail cell yeah I don't think it was
animal rape you know why cuz he was
winning the Pope so a bear can't [ __ ] a
bear Joe he just does a voice we need
the poos not real it's a cartoon you
know what what did you go counts if he
was a bear by spirit if he identifies as
a bear then he's a bear and I don't like
the fact that she set it up without the
science to back it up so let's continue
okay so this man is a voice actor his
name is Jim Cummings that is hilarious
he's been coming that is hilarious what
is his middle name
[ __ ] this guy why what'd he do let's go
why is it disappearing into a skull it's
so tiny in round he has been the voice
of over 250 characters he was in Winnie
the Pooh The Lion King he lying to you
known for Tigger Mickey Mouse the Mickey
Mouse villain named Pete T I double got
her yeah it's like these guys she boys
these oh so he's not win either yeah and
take a pizza paddle Geppetto file no
Geppetto was a pedophile he was [ __ ]
around
oh that's what you mean well I mean
technically he made the boy yeah the
[ __ ] he's [ __ ] Pinocchio so like oh
boy so we need a poo so hot what are you
started yeah you think about Madrid wait
he used the voice of Winnie the Pooh -
and Tigger
yes
all those pictures she just saw 250
characters like he's done it sounds so
different it was like Seth MacFarlane
when he does all the voices of Valley no
but I like to imagine it was just one
the allegations here he was married from
2001 to 2011 to his ex-wife Stephanie
who was 3 years old
so this is what she looked like so what
kind of animal did back in 2009 this
photo um so then they have two daughters
together and so she and right now
they're just having this really bitter
divorce
oh so it's alleged animal alleged yeah
see we ain't got no clue one incident
that happened just trying to throw shade
at him
we'll see she's trying to get full
custody of her children because she's
saying that he is like he's violent and
so one of the incidences she said that
Jim went over to her house and then
slapped her on the butt and then forced
himself on her in front of their
four-year-old daughter that he grabbed
her arms fun her around and which voice
did he do all that though yeah and
honestly this right now just sounds like
a kynges video come on now spun around
dipped her and then he [ __ ] kissed
her yeah then he put his hand on the
back of her neck and then kissed her
while holding her place against the wall
and then she said that after the kiss he
asked her if she could see him leaking
because that's what she makes him do
when he touches her oh wait that's very
specific oh that she felt humiliated and
degraded so he doesn't deny that that
happened
it sounds like husband and wife behavior
yeah so then he says that he remembers
it differently that like you know he
touched her slightly on the butt and
then she gave him a consensual hug and
then he was saying that the whole
incident was happy and that they were
laughing and then she said that his wife
who's much taller than he is and a
larger woman made no objection to
anything so he's claiming
I love his defense he's like do you see
how big his [ __ ]
she could've uh it was like she [ __ ] me
understand takes me to the wallet [ __ ]
me I'm Jamie Lannister and she's Brienne
of Tarth yeah so then another one she
says that she was raped by him in 2013
look how big she is hey big people could
get raped
so she said this other time without her
consent she would touch her butt her
groin her breasts and then hold her in
place trying to kiss her and fall into
her and then shoot he would all often
spank her in front of her their
daughters you know what this is really
difficult because that's really crazy or
like crazy yes okay so she's saying that
there's one time he asked to stay over
because he went to go visit them at like
she was staying at her parents house so
he went over and then she was like fine
you could stay the night so he did and
then she woke up finding him with his
penis out erect standing right over her
with her hand like holding yo his [ __ ]
his dick and then her daughter her
ten-year-old daughter was sleeping right
next to her and so he said they fixed
her sleeping situation yeah why these
kids like oh and the daughter sleeping
on the Shelf watching figures [ __ ]
kids everywhere how many kids do they
have two but wait she's asleep next to
her mom so that's not by the way put in
a shoe box put him in the room put him
away so anyway so then he he told her
like you know you need to make me [ __ ] or
else I'm gonna wake up our daughter and
so she ended up doing it because I felt
force that's the funny threat she was
just saying like wake up the daughter
Cummings well because she said that she
worried that she could not control he
would do in front of the daughter so she
it sounds like a bitter battle because
like all the other stuff that she's
claiming like or getting a divorce for
like he hasn't shown a pattern that she
can like these examples about sucks cuz
it seems like she's taking advantage of
the me to movement by trying to oust him
as a sexual predator she's actually
saying they
use a smaller Harvey Weinstein I don't
know cuz I can't say cuz I wasn't there
yeah we don't but just fine the evidence
which is a divorce is going on there's
all these you know it's like all the
stuff surfaces now there's more to it so
she's also saying and cuz I thought he
[ __ ] the eagle in front of her
something like no one else in this room
I just pitched like a Mongolian spread
the [ __ ] American flag blue so she's
also saying that he had a beaut he
abused on the ball of marijuana and
adderall he went to rehab for adderall
he was kicked out of rehab because he
continued to use adderall's
okay that all sounds true yes I mean why
no one in this room knows anything right
but that this shows the pattern of but
that also sounds like me I'm not trying
to defend them but also sounds like
things when you're in a marriage is like
a sense of confidentiality because
that's her partner your life partner so
hey I have a substance abuse problem and
then now it seems like she was helping
him but because of this divorce case I'm
era Oliver dirty line that wouldn't make
sense so she's trying to get full
custody I would have said the same [ __ ]
cuz that just shows I'm trying to show
the dark bility he's incompetent father
yeah but if you're if like is he is even
accused of any sexual assault with
anyone other than her so to speak like
his kids
what's the animal stuff do does the
animal stuff was another one depends on
what type of animal
so the animal stuff was it was the dog
involved in this so he put his dick in
the dog's paw and he was like you better
[ __ ] me off before I wake up the
puppies don't stop I put peanut butter
on my ballsack just for this no go okay
so hold dog incident was that he took
the dog outside
well she's claiming that it was over a
hundred agree
that day he took all put the dog in a
metal bucket and to punish the dog for
like I guess he liked Pete or something
inside the house and he left the dog in
that metal bucket for many hours and the
dog almost died is what she says but
then he says yeah I took him outside I
didn't put him in a metal bucket it was
plastic and it was a tub that's what I
was thinking I put him under it like the
tub over him so and then he says that it
was a veteran veterinarians
recommendation - that's how you
discipline this dog that sounds and then
he said that he forgot about the dog for
many he's like unfortunately I did
forget about the dog so he stayed there
for a long time but then afterwards he
took him out and then he took him to the
vet to make sure that he was fine is
what he says so that's the whole animal
abuse part of it yeah probably wouldn't
leave my kid i if I were the judge I'd
give the kid school all the stories do
sound like kind of neutral stories but
she's skewing them in her favor
yeah because it all sounds like I've
heard someone do this before yeah
because it's not like he punched me in
the face I have two black eyes it's like
he he he made advances on me smacked me
in the butt and hit me down it is that
way but she's saying that the kids were
always around that's why he's not a
competent she's just as at fault for
having the kids around all the time
what are you talking about like the kids
live in the house you didn't mean like
it's not like hey we're gonna go have
sex and then it's like in front of the
kids
no if the dude was like hey Jack me up
or I'm gonna wake her up grab the
[ __ ] can and leave the room when the
guy has a boner
they scientifically can't spread number
one we're off balance and number two
we're too scared that we're gonna fall
over and break our dick we can't read no
matter what just row
the scientists right now you should you
should get Bart hard and test his
quarter-mile speed versus soft but his
soft can't be right after you get him
soft it's like it's got a pretty gotta
be on the throbbing boner it's gonna be
very difficult his time is gonna be way
slower this other funny part like funny
how dare you I think it's a little bit
funny is that she says that he has
referred to his two daughters as n-word
babies what's like why she's different
though was it with the hard-on no is it
hard are hard ah you know what
I feel like these are all like inside
family things that are pretty normal
that she's just airing out what he's
saying that she has mental issues and
that she's taking medication so she's
making things up well this is from him
too it literally and he said that's
that's what it is there's I can't tell
who's right or wrong but it's I would
have to hear his allegations against her
or his you know because right now it
just sounds like everything is a in
defense of himself right and it's all
hers her accusation place two
restraining orders against him I should
mention oh how was it pretty important
if it is important I forget all these
little details we need to this one's a
little detail that's like the biggest
rain in order and still visiting yeah
big illegal thing yeah cuz I thought
they were married and together and then
they had a divorce she said my bad my
bad I think like if when people listen
to this we think that we're not we're
not in siding with the victim but once
again like you have to look at
everything just just because if you've
seen media now you have to look at the
whole story everyone's just in trouble
now yeah if they were accused they're
just wrong no matter if it if you're
younger to and you don't know anybody
who's going through a divorce this is
actually very typical it's very
different and start stating all these
things that are highly exaggerated to
their size so they can get custody of
yeah so this is something the horses are
nasty it's nasty so I think that if
you're young out there and
you don't know these type of situations
that you actually don't know people who
are married right this happens a lot you
know my dad then so when they were going
through divorce my dad trying to get
custody of me
he put a tape recorder underneath this
truck chair and then he got me
McDonald's so got me in a happy ass
place and he asked me a series of
questions like it was a conversation and
of course I'm super happy so he was like
oh I hope I as your food all the time
does is it oh who would you rather live
with you or your mom and then so if you
have all this evidence that he played in
court you're like yeah that's normal
parents leave kids are involved in a
divorce they are the number one pawns
that they're we yet they're both going
like that yeah and I yeah and like and I
don't doubt the fact that wives can be
raped Oh
it happens a lot it's difficult to even
say like what happened yeah but this
changes everything once you know she has
the restraining order cuz I'm supposed
to be over right so now you know that
like she's been having issues with him
so
so like the sexual assault hat if the
sexual assaults happened after the
restraining order then it seems pretty
plausible